one of the funnier lighter moments in
Game of Thrones season 6 is tormund's
adorable crush on Brienne of Tarth
Brienne doesn't reciprocate sadly but in
the books there are hints of another
woman tormund may have a secret romance
with you know how Daenerys is famous for
having a lot of titles she is Daenerys
Targaryen first of our name queen of
marine queen of the Andals and the
Rhoyne are in the first men lord of the
Seven Kingdoms protector of the realm
Khaleesi of the great grass sea
Stormborn the unburnt mother of dragons
Mesa and breaker of chains well in the
books
tormund too has many names they call him
tormund Giantsbane tall talker
Hornblower and breaker of ice torment
thunder fists husband to bears the made
king of ruddy Hall speaker to gods and
Father of hosts tomans quite a different
character in the books compared to the
show he's more funny always joking
drinking telling tall stories and one
tale he tells explains one of his titles
husband two bears the story goes that
one cold winter's night
tormund was drinking alone when he
decided to go visit a woman he knew
nearby he went out got a bit lost but
eventually found the woman and though
she fought him got her out of her furs
and had sex with her when torment woke
up the next morning he found his body
ripped and torn half his penis bitten
off and a she bares pelt lying beside
him turns out he had sex with a bear and
supposedly a bald bear is later seen in
the woods with the queerest pair of Cubs
behind her this story obviously isn't
literally true tormund's a notorious bag
of wind and lies called tall talker
after all but there are hints that the
story might be loosely based in truth
possibly revealing a secret relationship
between tormund and Lady Mage Mormont
house Mormont is a northern family based
on Bear Island
up near the wall they're led by Joe
Mormont till he joins the Nights Watch
then by Jorah Mormont till he flees
Westeros after selling slave speed ends
up serving with Daenerys
so now the leader of house Mormont is
Lady Mage who's called the she-bear so
the theory here is that tormund story of
a she-bear
is not really about an actual bear it's
about the she bear of Bear Island mage
Mormont and there are hints supporting
this tormund describes both the woman he
knows nearby and the Shiba as having a
temper mage is described as stubborn
willful and short-tempered mage is also
described as a stout and strong warrior
which fits with tormance descriptions of
a fine strong woman and of the fighting
she bear it is a bit confusing whether
mage is more the woman Torme's knows or
the she bear in this story maybe it's a
bit of both but the point is that
torment she bear story does seem to have
connections with the Chabert of Bear
Island lady mage and there's more cuz
lady mage has five daughters though no
one seems to know who the father is
or if mage has a husband majors daughter
Alassane who herself has a couple of
kids also apparently has no husband she
says Mormont women are skin changes we
turn into bears and find mates in the
woods everyone knows this again is
probably not literally true but it
supports the idea that Mormont women are
metaphorically she bears out in the
woods mating with men like torment this
could make logistical sense Bear Island
is very close to the wildling lands
beyond the wall mage says that it's
because of the threat of being carried
off by Iron Man or by wildlings that
Mormont women need to be warriors
so it had makes sense for torment and
mage to have met during a wildling raid
on bear island in torment story he
claims to have carried the Chabert back
to his home which in wildling culture
constitutes a marriage thus making
torment husband to the she bear of
course none of this sounds terribly
consensual on Major's part what with the
talk of carrying off and the fighting
she bare but there's reason to believe
this relationship between torment and
mage if it exists may be consensual and
positive and ongoing partly because of
the positive way Ella sane talks
the Mormont she-bears meeting in the
woods and partly because of the way
torment talks about the woman who lives
nearby
it sounds like an ongoing relationship
but also because an ongoing consensual
relationship could better explain majors
daughter's torment says that the she
bear bears him Cubs children
maybe these are majors daughters those
of the mysterious unknown father
tormund also mentions sons which might
mean that mage is the mother of some of
tormance four sons it sounds almost as
though mage chooses to keep her five
daughters but gives her sons to be
raised by tormund beyond the wall though
it's hard to imagine how mage could do
all of this secretly this is a lot of
kids to come from a secret relationship
across the bay of ice so maybe only some
of the kids are the children of tormund
with mage but even if it's only some
that could be very significant mage and
torment may not be the first wildling
non wildling relationship in the series
there's Jon and Ygritte and Gilly and
Sam but mage Mormont is the lady of Bear
Island a ruler in the north if her kids
have free folk blood in them if Liliana
Mormont is half wildling that could
really impact the attitudes of people in
the North who of course mostly hate
wildlings bridging this gap between the
wildlings and the Northman is becoming
more important with White Walkers on the
way and any relationship between tormund
and mage could maybe help with this
alliance the hatred between tormund and
wildlings also adds a layer of tragedy
to a relationship between torment and
mage they're separated by sides that
have been enemies for centuries
star-crossed like Romeo and Juliet with
the montagues and capulets
and of course by dance tormund and major
split further apart
tormund is at Castle black while mages
way down in the neck possibly involved
in a northern conspiracy the lovers are
now so far apart would that I could find
her again
tormund says so look there's no strong
evidence for a relationship between
tormund and mage Hallman's story may be
just a story and majors daughters may
have been fathered by
common man on their Island or something
but the hints and connections with
strong bad-tempered she bears are there
and the logistics and timing could work
so it is at least fairly possible that
husband two bears torment and the
she-bear mage Mormont get together on
one cold winter's night thanks for
watching this video
if you'd like to help a team of
academics in their study of the Game of
Thrones fandom go take their
questionnaire at the link below thank
you to the patrons for making this video
possible including the Lisa C Williams
Bret Jensen Ziggy folksmen gavin biggs
tagout Mac Stone Neil Roop Ram Roop Lori
to lava and full astern thanks also to
Pauline on Twitter Cheers